my first time long time I want to thank
you miss thinking that so it's a long
time ago for all of us as a matter of
fact so with their and it goes fast as
it does you know watching a homeland air
with my kids so it just shows you you
know time passes very quickly and I
don't think anybody's can duplicate what
judge did he's a frickin nature I've
never seen anything like it
his ability to just hit the ball out in
all directions with every swing is just
super firing it really I've never seen
anything like it you know it's just
bigger and stronger he's like these just
like the Ivan Drago baseball I've never
seen anything like it you know the very
few people that actually amaze you that
was amazing and just changed the game
I know they're playing with golf ball so
I know everyone's complaining about the
baseballs and they're right the pitches
are all complaining about it the
pitching coaches are all complaining
about it the balls juiced up we all know
it but the bottom line is for his
ability to hit the block I mean you know
we didn't even hit it well that the
opposite field was almost bizarre it
really was yeah I know if you point out
the baseball's are golf balls but
they're golf balls for everybody yeah
and he was no one else hit them like
that no and all year watching him no one
else hits home runs like this guy ever
this guy hits home runs in all
directions he hits it out on balls he
doesn't hit well when he hits it well it
goes 490 feet I mean it's a you know
he's six eight and he's trim and he's
athletic anyways a trim strong sinewy
280 pounds and he is a very we all
didn't see this coming he was not he did
not look like this athlete last year he
came back a different player he's
extremely athletic he runs the bases
well he feels well plus he also has the
it factor which none of us knew either
where he's already the leader of the
team he hey stands in front of his
locker after bad games he's graceful
he's classy he's got the whole thing
he's going to be the leader the Yankees
don't care who comes and they got a ton
of young talent okay who comes he's
going to be the leader now it's fair to
say at this young age 25 he seems Mike
like he's got the pulse of Derek Jeter
like the bay does right I know we always
try to compare everybody to him and it's
not fair but he gets it
some guys have brought up a certain way
he's very low-key
he's very classy he's very considerate
he's very thoughtful he understands what
the media's job is he knows someone has
to be there and finally a locker when
there's a bad loss he gets all that and
that's why naturally it's him that will
be the leader I don't care what Torres
or freezer or Sanchez or any of them do
this guy's the leader of the new Yankees
there's no question about it and I
tweeted this out last night Mike I know
you're not on social media George M
Steinbrenner the third would have loved
its call yeah it could say it oh we
would just you know he loved he loved
anything that was sensational
he got box office he you know he
understood box office he understood
entertainment and the entertainment
value of this guy you know Sanchez was
remarkable last year he was remarkable
last night in the first go-round but he
has human limits
this guy doesn't I mean this guy doesn't
have any limits right now he could have
put up another ten home runs last night
I mean he he just is bigger stronger
version of what we've seen everyone's as
well you know he's hitting the ball like
mannal mannal was 511 190 this guy is
6-8 to 85 he's the next generation of
player this is the real next futuristic
generation of baseball player and
another reason why Steinbrenner would
loved him I'm at Mike Francesca here in
the Rich Eisen show is he had a football
background and you know George loved
that whole football I love that this was
a coach and he loved all that stuff he
was an assistant on the Hank Stram and
he had that you know rah-rah used to
send out the misses which we all loved
which you know we created into an
industry I mean it just really he we all
miss time render because Steinbrenner
was great theater that's what it was he
understood the idea of of publicity
understood entertainment and he
understood good theater and he was good
theater and judges the one who will fill
the building the other guys are young
have a wonderful amount of young talent
and an inordinate amount of young
right-handed power which is in very
short supply they own it they have
almost
a whole well of it it's it's ridiculous
because phrases good and you know and
they have more coming but the bottom
line is uh this guy is just basically on
a different level right now it really is
well speaking of great theater Mike
Francesa here on the Rich Eisen show
your thirty four thirty or the one the
thirty four thirty about you and Chris
Russo is exactly that I mean any I'm
wondering what you thought of the final
piece here I liked it first of all the
guy did it I trusted Danny and identify
whose hands are all over it uh is a very
gifted guy I've known him for thirty
years I worked with them in the 80s at
CBS he was my college for the football
producer he went on to do a lot of
different stuff he was always a great
long feature producer he had a great
reputation to that so I knew Danny's
very artistic he was always an artsy
craftsy kind of sports guy so I thought
from that standpoint the thing was in
very good hands there was so much to
work from because we had such an
incredible amount of content when you're
on you know twenty years five days a
week forty six weeks five and a half
hours a day there's an incredible amount
of events of content to deal with so he
could have picked and choose but he did
get down the two things they really
wanted him to do which was the
relationship and tempestuous nature of
the relationship and also the impact we
had on on the industry which is is real
in one eye Trace and you'd understand
this very well
it started with us and we created a
two-man team in radio uh and then we
created these debate kind of opinion
shows list shows basically Pawnee
interruption came from us and everything
else came from the template of pardon
the interruption and that's really where
everything is gone and it did all start
with us and then went through Tony and
what they did with that show and it
really went to the next generation but
that's really what what it did and also
have created a viability for the am dial
the am dial was dying so sports talk
radio created very much a format that
the am dial could live with and there's
now like fifteen hundred you know all
sports stations in the country right if
when you're talking about your Ewan and
Mad Dog and Tony and will bond and
pardon eruption you're talking about two
tandems however who know each other
and the interaction between them genuine
but a lot of these a lot of these
debates shows though Mike seems
sometimes contrived and some of these
leads Hamas sighs well what do you find
that though I don't like that and I
think that hurts them dramatically
there was nothing contrived about what
we did and the thing that people didn't
grasp and maybe they do now was we were
always to individual performers who
prefer to be individuals who were thrown
together but then realized that we had a
great chemistry and a great ability to
work together even though we were always
trying to burst out at the seams and
work by ourselves so we we did things
differently than most successful teams
successful teams vacation together we
never did we each did to show apart for
long periods of time when the other was
on vacation we each had our own show
Saturday and Sunday morning for 30 years
so we always performed individually and
always brought an individual energy and
an individual cockiness to the show so
there was always this challenge where it
was almost like who was the fastest gun
at all times and always that was always
the edginess that that came that that
made like in a mad or different I think
because we were never just two guys who
always worked together we were two guys
who were always trying to challenge each
other well also works in the New York
atmosphere to the number of times out
here in Southern California Mike where
sometimes people think I'm angry but I
have to explain it's just the way I talk
I've lost I've lost oh yeah well you
know they must try different you know
this is completely different in New
York's probably even a little more there
although I don't think we're any more
rapid than Philly or Boston I think
they're just as rabid as we are and we
might even be a Ted Ted more
cosmopolitan than they are but Easton is
different I mean any athlete will tell
you that any media guy will tell you
that East is just different
Chicago is somewhere in between and the
West is basically comma those you know
few more minutes year with Mike France
si here on the Rich Eisen show so what
about the future Mike your run at WFAN
ends in the middle of December
this year what are you going to do what
are you gonna do you know I'm not at
liberty to say that's the agreement we
have okay you know they were very
conscious of that they didn't want
another situation like they had they
kept mentioning they didn't want to
situation like they had with Howard with
the last year was all about where he was
going and they had a very bad
relationship they wanted this to be very
good relationship it has been so the
deal is I can't state anything or agree
to anything until after 12:15
I really haven't rich you know people
have brought up a lot of what do you do
is there mic in the mayor talk in the
future and that's probably remote
because economics aren't in place he's
under contract I've never been free
before so on I'm looking at everything
they've allowed me to talk to people
I've talked to a lot of people I will
work I won't work Monday to Friday I
don't think anymore but I will work and
do some different things I like do
couple new things if I could you know I
just felt that 30 years was the perfect
time and 30 is saying I've been that
same job at the same time period of 30
years Monday to Friday that's a long
time it really is I just thought it was
time to you know to get out while things
were still good where they weren't
throwing me out I get there you know I
go out on your own powers is nice then
rather having getting thrown out because
you're not doing the job anymore so I
thought I thought that was positive and
that's why I just thought it was a time
to go to the timetable on it and I'll be
doing something I'm not sure exactly
what yet but I'll be around somewhere
and the fan will move to its next
generation and that's the way it should
be the fan will be around a very long
time it's an institution will be around
long after Mike and a mayor dog have
been forgotten what do you think of your
fill-in host yesterday Mike Christie
yeah he got enough attention that's for
sure and that's not going to fear
there's not going to be a shortage of
that he's an easy target but the one
thing about him and I do know this I
don't pretend to know them very well
I've talked to him five or six times
he's friends with the morning so it
doesn't really spend a lot of time with
me although I see Matt ballgames he is a
fan he is legitimate sports guy I don't
know that he has the depth of knowledge
he would need to do that every day's
that would have to be a learned thing
but he's clearly bright enough if he's
wants to do it I think if he really won
do it he could do it he's got a
toughness to him he doesn't back down
you're not going to hurt him with you're
not going to make this guy shrink by
yelling at him well I start a fight with
him he's up for a fight and you know
that's kind of his nature so I think he
could do it
it would take some transitioning for him
to do it he'd probably have to do it
with a radio guy but I think he's
capable of doing it I still think it's a
bit of a long shot but it is a
possibility
last one for you Mike when you step away
from the mic on December 15 2017 how
many wins did the Jets have at that
moment what do you think that's pretty
thing uh not more than three maybe two
can be a long it's going to be a long
long season and already
Donald is talking about not coming out
which would be typical jet walk because
I love that kid he's the next Ben
Roethlisberger he's the guy I would
dress him right now and if the Jets
would be typical that he would not come
out it would be typical jet walk it
really would be Mike Congrats on the
3438 you rich I much appreciate really
appreciate you calling in love to have
my daughter thank you thank you bye you
got that's my princess the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience if you like some of that
get some more of that on the Rich Eisen
show app follow all the information you
see right here on the Rich Eisen show